mercredi soir bruxelles faisait encore
la fête
quelques heures plus tard le silence
était lourd sur le parvis de saint
gilles
quatre mois après leur réouverture les
bars de la capitale belge ont été
contraints de refermer leurs portes
la raison des nouvelles mesures
sanitaires imposées par le gouvernement
suite à une hausse du nombre de
personnes positives au cou vite 19 dans
la région de la capitale
un nouveau coup dur pour les clients
mais surtout pour les travailleurs de ce
secteur
comment est-ce qu'on va gagner pour
payer des prêts dès les choses pour
nancy et le loyer tout l'électricité
tout ça ça va être catastrophique arrive
à un moment où on est en effet pourquoi
on est on est à vif
on a on a plus de réserves on a on a
quand même subi on a des employés qui
sont au chômage depuis au mois de mars
est aussi très difficile à vivre ça
serment comme ma réaction ce que je
trouve ça débile je trouve ça
complètement incohérent et déjà avec la
crise ça va déjà mal déjà comme ça ça va
très mal mais alors là je sais pas où on
s'en va ça va être le gouffre total les
bars ne sont pas les seuls concernés par
ces nouvelles mesures
salle des fêtes cafés salons de thé sont
également invités à fermer pour une
durée d'un mois
la consommation d'alcool dans l'espace
public est également interdite sur
l'ensemble du territoire pour éviter
tout rassemblement de personnes même en
extérieur
les restaurants sont aussi impactés si
leur fermeture totale n'a pas été
imposée tous devront fermer au plus tard
à une heure du matin
côté médecins les mesures sont soutenus
mais cela ne changera rien si personnes
notamment les jeunes ne changent pas
leurs habitudes
alors c'est bien de fermer les cafés
mais si les jeunes se retrouvent dans
des appartements dans des jardins ou
dans des maisons peu importe tous
ensemble voilà les comportements à
risque
vont se poursuivre donc effectivement
c'est une mesure qui malheureusement à
d'autres conséquences des conséquences
économiques et voilà tout ce qu'on
s'aimait mais probablement que c'est une
première mesure qui risque peut-être de
ne pas être là c'est donc une partie
importante de la vie bruxelloise qui est
mis entre parenthèses pendant un mois
sur les dernières 24 heures plus de 3500
cas ont été confirmés ces nouvelles
mesures de restriction sont donc
considérée comme primordiale pour
endiguer la propagation du virus dans la
deuxième capitale européenne la plus
touchée par le kobe 19 derrière madrid
mais devant paris